there's a rather common sort of behavior
or comportment that I've been observing
for years and years and when I was
younger in philosophy I did this myself
and I've been thinking about it actually
dwelling on it for some time because
it's a complicated phenomenon I don't
want to try to come up with shoot from
the hip simple judgments about things
because that's actually one of the
characteristics of what it is that I'm
going to talk about and so you know
before I go into this I should tell you
what I am actually going to talk about
so for years I've been observing in you
know YouTube comments and in classes and
online and face-to-face events and
conversations and other formats as well
that there's a tendency for people when
they are reading studying learning
interested in philosophy and perhaps
even more broadly to draw
connections that
are kind of there but not really there
and to lay too much stress upon this to
say x is just like y I think that these
two things are connected or similar and
sometimes there are real connections
there every once in a while we have
these insights and that's really awesome
but a lot of times these are what
Socrates and the theatitis would call a
wind egg it's an idea that's actually
stillborn it's not really true it's not
really good it's not really alive it's
it's going to be something misleading
and there's a tendency for some people
when they're studying particularly when
they're first getting into things and
getting quite excited
to lay too much stress on that and and
to do so in ways that often reinvent
wheels and you know the response that I
often give is no those aren't really
connected in the way that you think and
it you do better to actually focus on
how these differ from each other rather
than just how they're similar so what
are we talking about you know it's
people making connections it's people
noting similarities it's people making
comparisons and then coming to a
judgment that says that what's going on
over here in this thinker in this book
or passage or system or tradition or
whatever it is is the same as what's
going on over here and sometimes it's
phrased in a rather you know more
tentative way I kind of think that these
are what's you know going on here and
these are very similar to each other or
couldn't it be the case you know uh I
would like to think that XYZ but it
really comes down to the same thing
thing assuming and asserting
similarities connections that aren't as
strong as we'd think and this can extend
even to making analogies saying if this
is the case over here then we should
also expect this to be the case over
here now I don't want to Simply throw
cold water as they say onto this it's oh
that's air that's awful you don't have
any good grounds for what you're saying
no I don't want to do that
because I think that there's something
important about this I think that this
is
you know a reflection of the way that
the human mind does work as it's
developing and the human mind doesn't
just develop by itself it develops in
relation to other people right some of
whom might be are interlocutors online
or in face-to-face Encounters in the
same time some of whom might be from
books that we're reading you know their
takes their viewpoints right the
important philosophers think about the
fact that we can in fact read Plato and
get his own takes or at least the tanks
that he puts in the mouth of his
characters
on a whole bunch of other thinkers as
well sometimes we look at them and we're
like yeah that's pretty good sometimes
we're like oh he's being unfair to this
person so I I don't want to discourage
anybody from this Behavior I just would
like to say
maybe you want to think about what
you're doing and try to do it in a more
reflective a more prudent way which will
help you out and I think it's just as
important so here's one of the takeaways
from this
it's very exciting to to note
connections to note similarities
it's just as important though perhaps
not quite as exciting to pay attention
to disparities to pay attention through
differences to make distinctions to be
able to compare and contrast to say yes
these things are kind of the same but
they're also not the same they're also
unlike they're different they're perhaps
even opposed to each other in certain
ways I want to say that you you're not
going to be as successful with just
having the one without also bringing in
the other and this goes back to you know
ancient philosophy I think really and
basically every tradition there's a
tendency to classify things together to
on the basis of similarities and then we
have to make differences we have to be
able to say where they're unlike to each
other and how they're different and why
the differences matter so
how does this happen well I think that
one of the most common things one of the
most common ways in which this happens a
dynamic is that people are misled by
language and so it can happen in you
know a very let's call it rudimentary
naive way when somebody reads important
philosophers in a particular language it
will take English which is you know my
native language as an example
so let's say you're reading you know a
translation of Renee Descartes and uh
you know it's the meditations and he's
talking about ideas and thoughts and you
know things like that right and then
you're reading somebody else
say Nietzsche coming from German into
English as well and he's using the word
idea or schopenhauer is using the word
idea and you know you see that word idea
and you're like oh wow we've all got
ideas or we could also take an English
writer like David Hume right uh the word
idea isn't necessarily doing the same
work it's not necessarily referring to
the same thing in all of these different
texts and thinkers and it might not even
be doing exactly the same thing
for the same thinker within the same
work right there are different senses to
terms and we want to be aware of that
rather than like blurring them all
together and identifying or equating
them with each other this also happens
once people get a bit of you know
sophistication and realize that
a lot of the philosophy we have is
actually translated from say Greek or
Latin or other languages as well and
they pick up on certain terms and they
see that this term is used here and then
they see it somewhere else and they're
like aha these are the same thing and
I'll give you a prime example of this
the term logos right I've posted some
videos a while back on heraclitus and
the fragments that we have from his work
on nature you know just fragments that's
all we've got so we shouldn't really
draw too much from them we shouldn't go
too far beyond an interpretation what we
actually can you know legitimately say
he uses the term logos this is a common
term in ancient Greeks Plato uses it
Aristotle uses it all sorts of people
use it right it doesn't always mean the
same thing in each of these thinkers as
a matter of fact you can guarantee that
what
heraclitus is calling the logos isn't
the same thing as what Plato and his
characters and the dialogues are meaning
by it or what Aristotle means by it
because logos has all sorts of meanings
in classical Greek right one of them can
be this reason underlying everything you
know you could say that the stoics use
of the term logo sometimes has a
connection with heraclitus right
especially with little reference
heraculitis
but not always and the kind of comments
that I'll get are typically from people
who want to equate the logos and
heraclitus with the logos found in the
Gospel of John and say oh these are the
exactly the same thing and no no no
they're not they're very different from
each other and we want to attend to
these differences rather than making all
too easy and misleading identifications
with each other and you know I can give
you all sorts of other examples the term
virtue or you know in Greek right
um it doesn't even mean the same thing
in ancient philosophy
necessarily from one philosophical
school to the other I mean for Plato
strictly speaking a virtue although
being a disposition in US is really the
form of AD virtue you know Justice
itself that my Justice participates in
it's very different for Aristotle it's
different for the stoics it's different
for the epicureans you know we could go
on and on and on and you know we get to
the modern period where or especially
the late modern period where people
throw around the word Virtue and vice
and very often have no clue what they're
talking about they just mean you know
something good or something bad and they
lose a lot of the resonances that go
along with these terms throughout
history as a matter of fact you know
Aleister McIntyre you know devoted not
just a book but a whole bunch of books
just showing how the concept or the
notion or practice or whatever we want
to call it of virtue and the virtues has
changed from time to time and culture to
culture
critique another term that gets used in
a lot of different ways by different
people we got to be careful with this
right or another great one phenomenology
right Hegel writes the phenomenology of
spirit is somebody asked me recently is
that part of the phenomenological
movement that gets started with visceral
and there's a little bit of you know
fake history there as well because
there's phenomenology before glycerol
and other strains that are going on as
well he's not the one person that
everything goes through but
um no these people are using words in
rather different ways so we don't want
to like blur all of these things
together although there are
commonalities and connections and
sometimes even references back and forth
to each other so language is something
that can you know mislead us similarity
of structure is a second very important
way in which people sometimes get misled
they're they're like well it looks like
this person in their account is doing
things and they're making these
differences or distinctions here and
that's like what this person is doing
over here
I've seen this come up over and over
again so much so with certain authors
that I actually did you know some some
videos about it for example Plato and
Freud both have a three-part tripartite
uh breakdown of the Soul or psyche or
personality whatever we want to call it
right and there is actually a connection
between
one of the parts you know what Plato
calls epithumia it's translated as
appetite or desire for bodily Pleasures
Freud in fact it mentions Plato and
calls that the ID right there's a
structural similarity between the two of
them
but the higher Parts the you know thumos
and logos those are not in any way
equivalent to Freud's ego and super ego
I mean you could try to draw some very
superficial similarities you know the
ego is cut in between the ID and the
super ego just like the thumos got in
between the uh uh you know rational part
and the desirous part but that's
they're not the same at all as a matter
of fact
thinking about things that way will
mislead you you will either
misunderstand Plato or misunderstood
Stan Freud or misunderstand both of them
together by making a comparison and
connection between them that doesn't go
as far as you'd like to think it does so
that's a second thing and I think that
you know we can also say as a third
thing that's kind of related you know
the project of this person or the
purpose or the aim or the goal is this
and this person over here has a similar
project or Aim so therefore they're
doing the same thing they could be or
they might not be even within the same
school or movement or tradition people
aren't always doing the same thing as a
matter of fact just to bring up McIntyre
again one of the things that makes
Traditions healthy is ongoing debate and
even dispute about what the hell are we
doing here in this tradition so we want
to be kind of careful about that
I think that a fourth source for making
these
problematic conjectures arises out of
uncritically
relying you know not well-informed way
upon various people's classification of
thinkers or movements you know these
these designations that we give that
would lump in certain people with each
other are often quite artificial and
they hold to some extent they're
convenient ways of putting things
together in a box but the more that we
learn about them maybe you know some
vital differences arise you know for
example think about the distinction that
you may have come across in the past
between continental rationalists and
British empiricists and rationalism
teaches this and empiricism teaches this
and then you look at you know let's take
some of the big three
empiricists right lock Barkley Hume yeah
they got a lot of stuff in common but
holy crap do they have a lot of
differences with each other and then we
start bringing in others as well and
looking at interpretations of Locke or
of Barclay or or Hume or their their
critics within the same sort of movement
and wow there's a lot of differences and
even more so for the supposed
rationalists as well you know Descartes
is not Spinoza is not leibniz is not
Mall barrage is not our no that we could
go on and on and on people like to
generalize about you know German
idealism
that's a pretty loose movement you know
and there's a lot of key differences
within that and it's you know sometimes
it gets difficult to say exactly where
the boundaries of these movements or or
Traditions lie so you don't want to just
take somebody say so for philosophers
doing the same thing or being the same
you you want to actually read the text
and take a close look
and you know it is quite understandable
that
um
people who are studying philosophy
people who value philosophy people who
think that there's something right
rightly there to get out of philosophy
who find it interesting who find it
insightful enjoyable or even admirable
you know admirable in the sense of not
fully understanding it but being like oh
man I think there's something there
would be led to draw these
these conclusions about Connections or
similarities
sometimes they're right sometimes
they're wrong and so they would want to
you know map or connect up or you know
bring together uh these different
philosophers or their ideas or their
points of view or their assertions or
any of these these sorts of things
it's really important so now we get away
from you know why this happens and why
it's kind of okay for it to happen
it's really important to realize that a
term or a concept or a distinction or a
key practice or something like that
for real philosophers
they have a
a
situatedness they belong within a
context
they're not just like hanging there as
fruit to pluck and then take wherever
you want and turn into whatever it is
that you want I mean you can do that
but a lot of the
matters that we work with in philosophy
they kind of lose a bit when we do that
in the process and so you know paying
attention to the wider context that we
learn through studying a philosophy you
know if you're going to study Plato you
can make inferences after just reading
the euthyphro but you're going to know
so much more after you've read a lot
more platonic dialogues and you've
reread the Youth of fro and you've
reread those and you've gone back and
forth and thought about them quite a bit
so I'm going to close here by saying you
know it's good to have these
aha moments where you're like man what's
happening here is what's also happening
here it's good that's a thing that our
human Minds do and
um we just don't want to base too much
on superficial connections right we so
what can we do we can not just note the
similarities but also look for how
things are different think to yourself
hey I see a similarity here there
probably is going to be some important
difference and you know we should also
understand
that the positions that we have on what
a particular thinker if they are an
important you know and deep thinker uh
you know the position that we have is is
probably very partial you know so we
want to exercise a bit of intellectual
humility when it comes to that and
understand that there's a lot more for
us to find and then you know the other
thing that I would say is we want to be
good conversation Partners in the sense
of sharing conversational space well you
know we should realize that others don't
necessarily share our and enthusiasm for
the connections that we've seen and if
we do want them to appreciate these
connections first of all we have to make
sure that we're actually right about
that and that we're not like putting out
wrong information as if it is correct
um but we also you know want to explain
ourselves not just shoot from the hip
and say wow Nietzsche is doing the same
thing as this person over here or it's
exactly the same idea we don't want to
do that instead we should be a little
bit more careful and that's that's a set
of skills that are important for
philosophy as well just as important as
noting connections and having intuitive
leaps or things you know like that that
feel so good we want to do the careful
work both with the philosophers and upon
ourselves so I've already talked quite a
lot about that I'm sure people will have
some views on this and opinions and I do
want to say this I'll say this at the
very end
I can relate right to this this
excessive uh enthusiasm that sometimes
leads people to be dominating
conversational space and saying wow this
is exactly like this I did it myself as
an undergraduate I did it myself as a
graduate student I'm willing to bet I've
done it past graduate school and you
know so maybe it just takes a bit of
time and and uh you know getting humbled
from uh occasion to occasion to get
yourself out of this and so I'm kind of
trying to save you some of that time
yourself if you're this is one of those
if the shoe fits wears it sort of uh
conversations if it does fit maybe think
about what you're doing and whether it's
good for you to be so interested in
jumping from philosopher to philosophers
like oh Sim you know similar similar
similar similar same same same let's go
on them all together that's not really
good for you and it'll stand in the way
of your own philosophical development so
you know
there's some things here to think about
hope that it's useful for you and I'll
see you next time